[Music]
if you have faith in science it might be
hard to understand why people would
gather like this while a deadly virus
ravages America similar protests are
happening across the country some people
are here because of genuine fears about
job losses and economic recession others
are also here to push views on perennial
American issues always ready to voice
their distrust in authority disregarding
the medical experts if a symptomatic
people go back to work they could infect
other people who could die okay that's
an interesting hypothesis it's a fact if
they're asymptomatic how do they know
that they have it they don't that's the
point
so it's mysterious so it's just this
thing that they're saying so why is this
all a big conspiracy theory it's your
conspiracy theory any organic element to
this is being seized upon by
conservative groups using their
nationwide networks to coordinate
gatherings making the sentiment seem
bigger than the polls suggest
[Music]
small protests across the country
millions of Americans are saying
fractions to be lifted most people know
the virus itself will determine when
normality can resume these protests are
being amplified by right-wing media and
the President himself after Fox News
aired a protest Donald Trump tweeted his
support just a day after issuing
measured guidelines about the cautious
path states should take before reopening
the experts say Virginia is in no
position to do what these people are
asking in New York City obviously was
the epicenter for a while Virginia we're
obviously looking at a surge here and
we're definitely very concerned I think
just letting things go at a random we
will lose control of this very fast a
lot of effort has been put in a lot of
good measures in terms of lock down and
I think we need to be very mindful how
we go about opening those those doors
again like so much in America
coronavirus is now a partisan issue with
more Democrats than Republicans feeling
extremely concerned about it but this
virus does not discriminate with well
over 40,000 deaths and numbers still
rising these people are going to have to
wait Amanda Walker Sky News Richmond
Virginia